all right we're going to start today
looking at an interview
billed as an exclusive interview if you
can imagine that by right-wing radical
tv network
newsmax with former president donald
trump donald trump of course
giving a completely insane interview
lying about just about everything but
this is the man still at the head of the
republican party this is the man who
most republicans still say they would
vote for
this is the man who most republicans
still say did win in november
and they would follow him out of the
republican party to his own third party
or so they
say or so they say let's just get right
into it
we're not going to be able to look at
all of it but let's at least start
looking at some of it mr president thank
you for sitting down with us
uh this experiment of joe biden is
president it's only been
four months and in the short four months
america is enduring
numerous crises both abroad and at home
it seems our country is deteriorating
very fast even faster than i would have
thought your reaction
great question well it's pretty obvious
you look at what's going to happen
is even scarier the border is a disaster
we had the strongest border we've ever
had and within
a month it became the weakest and now
you have tens of thousands of people
flowing into our countries and
men so already okay already understand
the number of lies there
the border was a situation under trump
it's a situation under biden it's gotten
slightly better under biden
that's the situation there's a
seasonality to crossings which we've
already talked about
but this is already a framing that's
completely absurd
it's it's just this is fantasy world
framing
uh and this is what the entire interview
was let's continue
criminals frankly released from jails in
numerous countries we have people
coming in from the middle east we have
people coming in from everywhere
you go to the airport so just casually
that's another unproven unproven
statement
that there are people coming in through
the border from the middle east
he keeps repeating it they all keep
repeating it but there's not
actually evidence that that really took
place let's continue
joe how you doing you come through the
southern border and you just walk in
we're the strongest southern border ever
and it's very sad to see
uh the wall was so important you know we
built almost 500 miles of wall
remember that most of that was just wall
that was redone
that's all that's all it was i think
about 70 miles of new wall were added
just another lie
and within a month it would have been
finished and they ended it and of course
within a month nothing would have been
finished
he promised that by the end of his first
term there would be a wall across the
entire border
one more month would not have done
anything they ended it
took two and a half years to get the
approvals to do it i had to go to court
i had to do everything we got the
approvals
and so you have open spots and it's
ridiculous i hear they're going to close
them up but now
it's a big deal with the contractors
because those deals were those
those transactions were made it was all
complete but you look at
some scrambling things uh it's very sad
to see what's happening inflation is
going to be a big problem
it's going to drive so free association
now on to a new topic
a lot of things up and down whichever is
worse because
did you guys catch that inflation is
going to drive
things up and down whichever is worse
could be up could be down either way
it's definitely going to be very bad
things happen with inflation but you see
that happening all over lumber the cost
of lumber the cost of gasoline
you look at gasoline what's happened i
was at 287
was was high remember that gasoline
prices started climbing dramatically
under trump
uh presidents have very little to do
with gas prices but if they started
climbing under trump the reason was
there was a complete collapse in demand
for gasoline at the start of the
pandemic
at the end of 2020 things started going
the opposite direction
gas prices were going up under trump
they've continued up under biden because
the economy is opening and because there
is now demand that's when i
got involved right and uh it was in the
threes and a little bit in the fours and
then i got came in and i had it under
two dollars i had it
for a dollar eighty seven actually and
when i left it was
under two dollars substantially and now
it's it's going to be hitting four
dollars
meaning it's bigger than any tax
increase you can think of especially for
middle-income people so a lot of bad by
the way
that's also untrue if you look at just
the average miles driven by
middle-income people
gas at 370 versus gas at 190 it is a
difference
but it's it's not significant in the way
donald trump wants you to believe
relative to so many other things child
tax credit
covet cash everything is a lie things
are happening i don't think we're
respected
in the world that's again another
factual demonstrable lie
respect and approval of the united
states
has skyrocketed since trump left we have
studies on this
pew global research we have we've looked
at them dramatically better
opinion of the united states around the
world
since donald trump left everything is a
lie my friends
right now there would never moves on
taiwan by china now you have bombers
flying over taiwan
russia would have never encircled
ukraine
like they did kim jong-un was somebody
that i had a great relationship with we
weren't
going to have any problem with him in my
opinion and now you look at what's going
on there a lot of bad things are
happening
i want to ask you about the wuhan lab
reporting this week from the wall street
journal
about workers they're being so sickened
as far back as november of 2019 that
they were
hospitalized yeah the corporate media
now the ship and we're going to talk
about this
uh later today and tomorrow full bias
corporate media is starting to come
around to recognize
that perhaps that is the origin in fact
of the china virus
even dr fauci is changing his tune do
you feel vindicated
and again his corporate media is
starting to come around to recognize
dr fauci is not changing his tune okay
dr fauci has said all along investigate
things but
right now we don't have evidence this
was a man-made bio-weapon
i have no doubt about it i had no doubt
about it
i was criticized by the press because
china has a lot of people taken care of
they took care of hunter they took care
of joe they took care of everybody
didn't they
and people didn't want to say china
usually they blame it on russia it's
always russia russia russia but i said
right at the beginning it came out of
wuhan and that's where all the deaths
were also by the way when we first heard
about this
now of course remember it came out of
wuhan
is very different nobody denies that
that was the human
centered infection source the question
is
was it an engineered bio weapon as they
claim
was it naturally occurring studied in a
lab and it accidentally leaked
uh i have no problem investigating those
things as i've said
from the beginning but donald trump says
obvi i know exactly what it was how does
he know he doesn't know anything about
this stuff there were body bags dead
people laying all over
wuhan province and that's where it
happened to be located so
to me it was very obvious i said it very
strongly and i was criticized really
strong
people are agreeing with me so that's
okay when it comes to china the more we
learn about their malfeasance regarding
the virus and what they knew very early
on
and lied to them okay so this is just
normal trump um i guess we would call it
like trump uh
he goes into xenophobic stuff i want to
skip ahead
because of our limited time um to
another part of this interview let's
continue
probably you know tens of millions of
lives worldwide
mr president you mentioned gasoline and
uh right the specific
statistics are on election day it was
220 a gallon national average according
to department of energy right now it's 3
11. that's a massive move
incredibly quickly since election day i
want to ask you about inflation no more
bro
did you see what they did there guys did
you see what they did since election day
really well who was president
november december and most of january
this is how they do it okay under big
picture
presidents have very little influence
over gas prices
micro why are we now including since
election day
because they know that gas prices
started jumping in late summer of 2020
under trump and they continued
increasing
under trump and yes then then they
continued increasing under joe biden
this is how they take a phenomena that's
observable
and they politicize it there's very
little to politicize actually
about gas prices biden or trump broadly
because you did business in the 1970s
the last time the u.s saw
really aggressive inflation a lot of
people if they're young have never
operated in that kind of environment
in america what does this portend for
americans this new
biden inflation spike biden inflation
spike
let's listen well it's going to be ugly
when you look at the cost of a house
just the materials for a house it's up
30 or 40 percent in the last few months
especially lumber lumber they say you
can't even get it
perhaps they're closing down all their
forests for environmental reasons i
disagree
i said let's buy our lumber from
ourselves
so we go to canada and canada is a very
good they are very good negotiators in
canada
i did the usmca which was one of the
great achievements because nafta was so
bad it was so
horrible worst trade deal ever met all
right so
so again here there's just so much first
of all the differences between us and
mca and nafta are relatively modest okay
trump touting usmca is some miraculous
replacement to nafta
just we've done we've done deep dives on
that completely false
this issue of connecting biden to the
increase in real estate prices
uh and lumber first of all under normal
scenarios and during 2020 trump bragged
housing prices are up
trump considered it a badge of honor
housing prices are up that's the sign of
a good market trump's a real estate guy
housing prices are up means developers
like trump make more money
now the same phenomena which of course
is a result of
slowed down supplied lines during the
pandemic combined with people wanting
bigger spaces so that they can work from
home in perpetuity
have driven up the cost of housing in
some markets
and it has made lumber uh a scarce
resource
okay and now trump is saying well that's
bad well you
you were saying that this was good and
it was a sign of how great things were
when you were president it's all
whatever they need to make of it at the
time
although the deals they made with china
were pretty bad too i will tell you that
but
the worst trade deal ever made and i got
it done so we have a great trade deal
now
but they close up forests they don't
want to take down
any trees so we end up buying them from
other countries all right so trump doing
economics always risky
and it makes no sense i want to skip
ahead to another part of the interview
just to give us a sampling of everything
that's going on here so
uh it's very interesting what's
happening so i greatly
respect what some of the governors are
doing in some of the states i think they
can solve the problem maybe better than
the federal government
okay but regarding the federal response
if the republicans do retake
the congress as you're very much working
toward in 2022
if you decide to run again and you win
in 2024
in a potentially hypothetical second
trump term what can be done to counter
the power
of these oligarchs well i think what can
be done and very
strongly and uh when you say oligarchs
it's an interesting term but yeah
i just say big tech because what they do
is illegal but they also
silenced what should have been the
biggest blockbuster story of the entire
campaign
uh you know that eye certainly
experiences from the campaign side the
fact that the hunter biden
the laptop from all story was completely
censored and suppressed by big tech
this is the big story for them that
wasn't told
um an incredibly flimsy conspiracy
theory
about the son of the democratic
candidate for president
that's the big story that they believe
was not told
okay my view that justifies labeling
these operators as oligarchs is that
fair well
a lot of things are fair look that was
when we first had
uh silencio that's when we first said
silence
zalenzio that's a little zvanish
with hunter biden because it was very
bad for the democrats that was a very
bad
issue and we'd bring it up and i have to
tell you the new york post was
incredible what they've done
is incredible and it is it is incredible
that's true
yeah the abuse they took it was you know
i think it's a great newspaper actually
and a lot of people are relying on it
more and more
too bad yeah but they are so just i mean
a lot of people rely on fox news too
it's scary
done an incredible job in that in that
regard but they took tremendous
abuse but that's when you first saw
silence they silenced
a newspaper it's the oldest newspaper in
our country i believe and it's a big one
but they silenced a newspaper in our
country because they were talking about
hunter biden
and the senate we held if i weren't
involved in the senate races nobody ever
says this
i believe it would be 60 to 40 right now
with the democrats leading by so this is
a very interesting
revisionist history understand that
donald trump becomes president of the
united states as the head of the
republican party
in 2018 republicans lose the house of
representatives to democrats
in 2020 republicans lose the senate to
democrats
50-50 with kamala harris as the
tie-breaking vote and in 2020
republicans lose the white house
they lost everything under trump and
trump is somehow
still making himself the hero of his own
fairy tale by saying well
listen many of the seats we held in the
senate were thanks to me
this guy was behind kelly lefler and
this guy was behind david perdue and
they both lost in their special
elections
uh in jan on january 5th and even though
it's abundantly clear
that they lost partially because of his
mishandling of the pandemic partially
because
he just made this party a laughing stock
for year after year after year
and he has the gall to say thanks to me
it's only 50 50.
it could be it would have been even
worse if it weren't for me 10 instead of
50 50.
and mitch mcconnell lost two seats that
he should have had he kept talking about
we're gonna give you six hundred dollars
they're gonna give you two thousand
dollars
who can win a race like that he said you
won't get a penny more
to the public you won't get a penny more
they're voting
and they're saying 2 000 and he's saying
600
he lost those two senate seats so we
have 50 50. i think you would be 60
40 if i weren't endorsing if you look at
so there it is thanks to donald trump my
friends
republicans at least can obstruct things
which need
60 votes 21 minutes
on newsmax of pure propaganda
lies delusions and complete and uttered
meaningless distortions and republicans
love it they love it and this is what
they want more of in 2022
and this is what they want more of in
2024.
is it going to happen i wish i could say
definitely not
but uh this is the republican party that
we're talking about
okay um find the entire interview if you
want to go to the newsmax youtube
channel remember that monday memorial
day we're doing our one day membership
special
membership bomb on monday we'll do a
huge discount off of membership
for the federal holiday if you would
like to be notified
make sure you're on my newsletter sign
up at davidpakman.com quick break
back after this one of our sponsors
today is
helix sleep and it's a sponsor i'm
thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and they will pair
you with a mattress that will be perfect
for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video